so today we have speaking of Jake
webinar a small key oddity is the beta
growl professor of contemporary African
Christianity and Pentecostal theology at
Trinity Theological Seminary in Accra
Ghana he also serves as the vice
president of the seminary he served as a
visiting scholar at Harvard University
Luther Seminary he was a senior resident
scholar at OMS C here in New Haven and
most recently at Yonsei International
University in Sangu South Korea he's the
author of the African charismatic s--
contemporary Pentecostal Christianity
he's a co-editor with Kenneth Ross and
Todd Johnson Christianity in sub-saharan
Africa which was released by Edinboro
University Press in 2017 he's a
co-editor with Frieda Ludwig of African
Christian presence in the West he's a
lead editor of between Babel and
Pentecost migrant readings from Africa
Europe and Asia that's gonna be
published by Peter Lane Kwabena has
published many articles and
internationals journals relating to
christianity as a non-western religion
he's married to Theodora who is with him
today
so welcome so we're happy to have both
of you here so last time we were
together was in in Ghana in March and we
had a very good time you host it as well
so we we hope to do the same to you
thanks
good evening and I like to thank Michael
for one words of introduction and also
to thank my senior friend and colleague
lemon and both of you for bringing me
here
of course as I said my wife is here and
also it's good to be in the midst of
familiar faces everybody here is
familiar so I probably can say what I
like and get away with it thank you
the topic that I chosen to speak on is
actually one that so developing title
does one Jerusalem my happy home
exploring pluralism democratic
governance and Christian pilgrimage as
religious equalization in contemporary
Africa understanding is that you had
something about Nigeria last week but
it's impossible to mention Africa
without Nigeria and I I do tell my
friends who visit Africa that once
they've been to Ghana in Nigeria they
are covered they don't have to go
anywhere else so it's good it's good to
be here now so this presentation
reflects and on and articulates
religious and Theological response to
the development of Jerusalem as a place
of pilgrimage for Christians in Africa
now in new heretics involving its
religious significance as equal to Mecca
the biblical Jerusalem has been
reinvented and developed as an important
pilgrimage location in contemporary
African countries
there are agitations for sponsorship
with some Christians requesting
government's to help support such
pilgrimages in the same manner in which
Muslims are supported to perform the
Hajj in Mecca now most of my examples
for this discussion come from Ghana with
some references to destitution in
Nigeria pilgrimage is understood here as
basically a religious activity and I
distinguish it from tourism although
there is such an expression as religious
tourism the two are related but not the
same that is tourism and pilgrimage
because tourism is usually a social and
recreational activity and religious
tourism often takes people to sites that
possess historical religious
significance pilgrimage on the other
hand is a conscious attempt to visit and
perform religious activity our physical
locations associated with supernatural
revelations power and presence I speak
here of that which make aliyah day would
describe in terms of a higher funny and
that is supernatural revelations of
power and presence in lijo stems the
tradition that is most popularly
associated with pilgrimage is Islam in
logistics that is what we have all come
to know and the reason for this is not
how to find that the Hajj or pilgrimage
is an important pillar in Islam now
pilgrimage is also is not unknown in
Christianity and within Christianity the
stream that comes closest to the
performance of pilgrimage as an
institutionalized religious activity is
Roman Catholicism for example our Lady
of Lourdes grotto in France
which has been existence since Sumerian
operations there in the middle of the
19th century and the papacy in room are
two of the most permanent sites for
Catholic pilgrimages
if you come to Africa the African
independent churches have also developed
their own pilgrimage sites for example
in the Belgian Congo the burial site of
Simon Kim Bangu or of the leaders of the
one of the most prominent Africa
independent churches was buried in a
place call and come by Jerusalem and
that location has become an important
pilgrimage site in Ghana where I live
Misano
is another pilgrimage site and that is
where the founder of the of that
independent check has been buried in
other words Christians have developed
their own pilgrimage sites both locally
and internationally now what I do here
is to examine the import of an
invitation from the government of Ghana
to Christians for sponsorship for
pilgrimages to Jerusalem I look at the
political fallout from this invitation
the theological significance of such a
pilgrimage based on responses from
various Christian organizations that got
involved in the drama now the argument
from sections of the public suggesting
that government support for a pilgrimage
to Mecca was a misplaced priority and
this was not surprising because people
felt that pilgrimage is religious
activity and whether we are talking
about Christians or we are talking about
Muslims the government should not get
involved
there was a private advertisement that
was put on in newspapers in Ghana
advertising for people to apply if they
wanted to go on pilgrimage to Jerusalem
and very interestingly there's this
advertisement described the experience
in Jerusalem as a fifth gospel we have
the four Gospels Matthew Mark Luke and
John and the advertisement explained
that the fifth gospel that the four
Gospels are what you you read the fifth
gospel is what you experience and you
experience the fifth gospel by going to
Jerusalem
now I argue in the paper that factors
such as multiparty democracy with its
need for popular votes they desire for
dominance of public space through what I
call religious equalization in all areas
of national life from politics to
education by the to abraham ik religions
of Christianity in Islam have
contributed immensely to the
developments in which Christians and
Muslims contests for leaders visibility
through pilgrimage media technology has
become a critical facilitator of these
contexts in Lee Jos equalization during
a personal visits to Israel in May 2015
I was surprised to see people connect
with important places listed in the
Bible in a certain intense
religious manner for example when we go
to the Upper Room there were people
there praying for a fresh art pouring
under of the Holy Spirit upon their
lives has happened to the Apostles on
the day of Pentecost
I met a group of African Catholics from
Zimbabwe celebrating the mass with about
10 bishops in attendance and they were
there in their fall Episcopal vestments
and after the mass they visited a couple
of places and as I noted treating
Jerusalem as if it were a Christian
Mecca the questions I asked what is
their legal theological significance or
the development of Jerusalem into a
pilgrimage location in a fashion similar
to what we find with Mecca in Islam now
this question is petty patent for me
because in Christianity at least from a
biblical viewpoint pilgrimage has not
been institutionalized so what does the
attempt to institutionalize Jerusalem as
a pilgrimage Center mean for a faith
that has become a minority faith in the
place of its Beth for example in Ghana
the news about Jerusalem and its
institutionalization as a place of
pilgrimage first came up in the
newspapers the first newspaper to
publish this was a paper called the
daily guide and as it turned out this
was in 2013 the government through its
Minister of Youth and Sports was
facilitating this pilgrimage to
Jerusalem through the provision of
resources the president of the country
then had to come out to explain why this
was being done
one of the reasons giving was that a
press in Jerusalem were to help reverse
some of the economic difficulties that a
country was supervising was was
experiencing the statement of the
government read in part and I'm going to
read the full statement part of the
statement to you it says over the years
various Christian and church
organizations have called on government
to sponsor and address the various
challenges that they have encountered
during their holy trips to Israel it is
in response to all these several calls
that the government then decided to
facilitate and coordinate the pilot
pilgrimage to Israel to help address
some of the some of the challenges
Christian groups often counted on past
rates which is nothing new as government
has been doing for the Holy Muslim
pilgrimage to Mecca
it is deeply heartwarming that even at a
time of listen the statement several
Christian organizations churches and
pastors have requested appealed and
submitted names to be added to the list
for them the opportunity to trace the
footsteps of Jesus Christ and walk where
he walked pray for their families their
churches and their country is an
opportunity did not want to miss and a
potential life transforming events and
of course so this is a government
statement when it came under fire for
use in state response says resources to
sponsor a pilgrimage to Jerusalem the
whole point was that Muslims were being
supported and therefore if Christians
are making the request government has no
option but to support the Muslims to go
on their pilgrimage to Jerusalem
now we thought that was the end of the
matter but this year the new government
has sponsored at least two trips to
Jerusalem which means that the whole
idea of the development of Jerusalem as
a pilgrimage has become part of the
government agenda the debate on whether
the sponsorship by government of leaders
pilgrimages continue or not a third been
debated in public I took note of some of
the views expressed by members of the
public and I'll read just two of them
for you one person wrote in the mirror
which is a very important weekend paper
in Ghana one person wrote I can't for
amid understand why a government with so
many responsibilities is keen on
facilitating the pilgrimage of two
hundred pastors to Jerusalem the point
is to be made however that the
government has no business sponsoring
religious activities there's a clear
case of misplaced priority and
insensitivity on the part of both
government and the so-called men of God
as somebody's view against government
sponsorship of pilgrimages there is one
that supported the whole idea and I read
that one for you too I don't think it is
out of place for government to
coordinate a pilgrimage to Jerusalem
there have been caused by the Christian
Committee on government to sponsor and
address the various challenges they have
encountered during the Holy trips to
Israel and it is in response to these
several calls that government decided to
facilitate and coordinate this pyramid
so as to address of the challenges
Christian groups encountered on past
trips this facilitation for me is
nothing new just as government
has been doing for the Muslim pilgrimage
to Mecca and of good so we have two
people here responding to pilgrimages
one against it the other for it now the
reference to government sponsored Muslim
pilgrimage and backrub pilgrimage to
Mecca in the mirror viewpoint that I
have read is very significant a number
of Christian leaders interested in the
project pointed to the sponsorship for
Christian pilgrimages as deserved
because already government was
sponsoring Muslims and that is why I
call this an exercise in religious
Equalization if you are doing it for the
Muslims then you got to do it for us too
that was the argument
unfortunately the Christian churches in
Africa particularly Ghana in Nigeria
have never spoken with a single voice on
this matter of pilgrimages and
government sponsorship in the particular
case before us the responses from
churches regarding the appropriateness
or otherwise of a government facilitated
Christian pilgrimage to Israel were
varied and the debate is still ongoing
the Ghana Catholic Bishops Conference
the Christian Council of Ghana and the
gonna Pentecostal and charismatic
Council largely rejected the offer of a
privately sponsored and government
facilitated pilgrimage to Israel now
that is not to say that when given the
opportunity individual members and
leaders would necessarily reject the
offer to go and print material Salam the
official responses from these churches
gave two reasons for the rejection of
the government sponsored pilgrimage the
first was that pilgrimage to Israel was
not to be prioritized
of our problems within the country
second that prayers for Ghana would be
effective when offered in the country or
let us say equally effective when
offered on location however there were
also Christian leaders mainly belonging
to the independent charismatic streams
of the faith who were all for the
Christian pilgrimage the general line of
thinking has been that sir the
sponsorship of the Hajj is not going to
stop the Christian community may as well
accept whatever the government will be
able to do for them in that direction
after all in Nigeria Christian churches
benefit from sponsorship to Jerusalem so
why not in Ghana indeed as it turned out
some independent pastas with connections
in government had started requesting for
such sponsorships under the previous
administration
it is thus important to place our
discussion within the context of the
historical relationship between
Christianity and Islam in Ghana and also
in Nigeria the information from the
religious studies card data from Nigeria
is that the country in terms of numbers
is split equally between Christianity
and Islam the case of Ghana is slightly
different in that officially Islam
commands 15% of the population but
Christianity has seventy percent except
for a few and sporadic skirmishes the
two faiths have lived in peace
especially in Ghana in November 2017
that is this month the Christian
Association of Nigeria P rec SC call on
the president of the country Muhammadu
Buhari addressing the president one
reverend dr. Sampson
hola subbu are you coonley
president of the association fund
president Buhari for receiving them and
assured him that he was in the oppressed
during his surgeon abroad to seek
medical care for our purposes there are
three things in the address that this
person gave that are important for us
the that the president of the Christian
Association of Nigeria requested the
president of the country Mohammed Bora
have worried to a draw Nigeria for
religious organizations such as the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation it
also appeared with the government to
help Christians in the north to gain
quickly what is referred to as
certificate of occupancy for churches
when you are going to build a church in
northern Nigeria you need a certificate
of occupancy and the idea was that the
Muslim governors were making it
difficult for Christians to obtain such
certificates and then the Fed requests
to their Government of Nigeria was to
address the lopsided nature of political
appointments in in Paris government
because it seemed to them that I say
Muslim president he was favoring Muslims
in the appointment to political office
the situation in Ghana is not dissimilar
in post-colonial Ghana Muslim community
leaders established English Arabic
schools in response to the impact and
influence of Christian Mission schools
in the country these bilingual schools
were created to provide Muslim families
with an alternative to sending their
children to Christian Mission schools
their principal goals were to prepare
students to compete for positions in
government
business and other professions and to
inhibit the possibility of Muslim
children converting to Christianity so
they established this English Arabic
schools for Muslim children because they
did not want Muslim children to grow up
in Mission schools in Ghana the leaders
of Industry and public service in Ghana
have seen the colonial era been
overwhelmingly Christian because
Christians took formal education
seriously Christian evangelization in
sub-saharan Africa has right from the
outset taken place through formal
education Islamic communities were
suspicious of the mission schools
fearing that their children who said in
these schools would convert to
Christianity and so the principal goal
of the English Arabic schools was for
the protection or insulation of Muslim
children from Christian influence and
Islamization through formal education
within a system of religion
socialization the Muslim teachers
intended the schools are centers of
missionary outreach and to help Muslim
children compete with their Christian
compatriots when it came to occupying
responsible positions in public service
so the point is that the contest has
already had has already been going on
within the arena of Education and this
is important for the Muslim community
because their lack numbers of children
of Islamic background who were out of
the regular school system and in Ghana
and I believe this exists in other parts
of Africa to Islam has been associated
with lack of formal education and this
is very evident in the labor front where
a lot of menial jobs in the country
especially security work
is associated with Muslims it doesn't
mean as only Muslims who do that work
but because education within the Muslim
community it's not very strong we find
them in all these menial being these
menial jobs early this month the
Parliament of Ghana started considering
a bill to create what is called the
Sangha Development Fund
there are zone goes everywhere in Ghana
and these are deprived communities
Israeli occupied by Muslims and so there
is this attempt to try and as it way
help young Muslim children to be able to
compete with their Christian compatriot
and that's how I think this whole debate
on Muslim and Christian pilgrimage
should be understood in fact in 2012
Sunday of goon Tala a Nigerian wrote an
article for Christianity today the title
was do pilgrims progress it talked about
how many Nigerian pilgrims took such
pride in Knights in themselves as JP
Jerusalem pilgrim on return from the
pilgrimage the Nigerian government
sponsors almost 100,000 Muslim pilgrims
to Mecca annually the Christian
sponsorship caters for bad effect of the
Muslim figure and thus in Nigeria so it
seems to me that Ghanian Christians are
taking a cue from their friends in
Nigeria who have been receiving support
from government to go on pilgrimage so I
make the case that the attempt by
Christians in Ghana and Nigeria to seek
government sponsorship for pilgrimage to
Jerusalem and citing the sponsorship of
Muslim
images as an example of the atom and
amounts to pursuing religious
equalization it is like suggesting that
since we all pay taxes Christians must
be sponsored in the same manner that
Muslims are sponsored a Kennedy has
noted how the world over
relations between Christianity and Islam
have gone through many incarnations
marked by dialogue polemics cordial
disputations and victaulic
confrontations the government is
vulnerable in the face of such requests
because this amounts to forms of
religious patronage from which some
political advantage could be obtained
through votes at the polls there is some
attempt to mechanize Jerusalem that is
to turn Jerusalem into a Mecca the
Christian equivalent of Mecca within
Democratic Africa we introduce this work
by referring to the fact that legislator
images or care in different streams of
Christianity especially Catholicism
there are local national international
gruder's in Catholicism where the
faithful visit to pray and to seek Maron
interventions for various aspects of
life Jerusalem however does not have the
same significance in the Christian faith
as make AHA's in Islam it is horrible
Etiwanda the sections of the leadership
of the church and members of the public
continue to point out in media
discussions that God is not bound by
space and time and prayers offered
anywhere reach him
Islam is a religion that is rooted in
specific geographical places Mecca and
Medina
- which faithful Muslims are expected to
make a holy pilgrimage in the course of
their lifetimes beyond that Islam is
also connected to a single language
Arabic and the Quran as we know is
memorized and recited around the world
in
Arabic and translations of the Quran
into other languages usually not
considered genuine and inspired
expressions of his truth indeed in
Christianity the democratization of the
Bible altered patterns of authority
power and governance in the life of the
church and the Christian message was no
longer in the custody of any group of
interpreters so there's some difference
there on the substantive issues of
pilgrimage between Christianity and
Islam I argue that whereas in Islam
pilgrimage constitutes a major pillar of
the faith Christianity has no such
historically recommended geographical
center of religious ritual in other
words beyond tourist interests and its
ability to help the Christian pilgrim
encountered a place of Jesus's birth and
ministry Jerusalem has no religious
significance for historic Christianity
as we know the Christian faith became
detached from a geographical center in
Jerusalem within the fence within the
first two generations of existence in
the New Testament the church spread to
the cosmopolitan city of Antioch who
became the center of its missionary
outreach throughout the Roman Empire
while 2,000 years of history include
Jerusalem falling and being destroyed by
enemies and then been recaptured in
various ongoing conflicts through the
centuries the vitality and growth of the
Christian faith were not dependent on
the status of its geographical origins
in fact Christianity is one of only two
world religions the other being Buddhism
that remains a minority faith in the
place of his faith the faith has also
not been disseminated in the language of
its founder and
in the biblical accounts we hear Jesus
for example telling the woman of Samaria
believe me woman a time is coming when
all worship or who worship the father
will do so neither on this mountain nor
in Jerusalem a time is coming and has
come when the true worshipers will
worship the father in spirit and in
truth for the other kind of worshipers
the father seeks God is spirit and his
worshipers must worship Him in spirit
and in truth
Mecca the original theater of the
revelation of Islam has retained its
religious significance for all Muslims
and this is demonstrated in the Qibla
the direction in which they attend in
prayer jesus' direction in terms of
where to pray did not refer to any
particular geographical location or
place when you pray he said go into your
room close the door and pray to your
father who is an unseen then your father
who sees what is done in secret will
reward you
in this direction under walls speaking
about the translate ability of
Christianity node's Christians have no
abiding city no permanent secret sites
their new Jerusalem comes out of heaven
on the last day and of code it was after
the exile that Jerusalem was rebuilt
with the second temple which became an
important Centre for worship and a focus
of Israel's religious and cultic
identity that was obviously not the last
temple but the Jews in terms of their
importance so each of them are sacred
places for the worship of Yahweh Douglas
Davis explains the Contin relevance of
Jerusalem in terms of its theological
place in Christian thought saying the
idea of a heavenly Jerusalem in
Christian thought offers a dramatic
example of the way an actual place
comes to function symbolically as an
expression of faith and hope pilgrimage
is a very important religious activity
for many religions including certain
streams of Christianity as I have noted
Roman Catholicism for example they are
undertaking to various grotus
including to Lourdes in France which I
have mentioned of the most important
places of pilgrimage but we have argued
that although pilgrimage is not alien to
Christianity and the official
theological and institutional levels it
does not carry the same weight as it
does in Islam the sponsorship of the
more organized and centralized Islamic
Hajj by some governments in Africa has
contributed to a subtle contest for
public space and recognition that has
occurred between Christianity and Islam
much of this contest takes place within
the political arena in Nigeria things
have spilled over leading to physical
clashes and even bombing of churches
during worship especially in the Muslim
north in Ghana
chrisarah tea is a dominant religion as
we have noted Christian missionary
education date in Belgium middle of the
nineteenth century men that
evangelization took place through formal
education until fairly recently most
important public office holders were
either Protestant Christians or peasants
with Christian education the Muslims
have fell disadvantaged and from a
position of suspicion of formal
education through machine schools they
have now started to draw the attention
of their communities to the importance
of Education for public life there are
many now many Muslim basic high schools
in Ghana including an Islamic University
the Christians have gone on the
offensive because they feel that the
government is privileged in Islam in
many areas
it started in the mid 1990s with an
introduction of two Muslim holidays
Ghana never had any national Muslim
holidays until the mid 90s
now the Muslims have been granted - and
I've also talked about the Zongo
Development Fund that is going to
benefit Muslim children and so it looks
like the Christians are requesting for
this support to go to Jerusalem in order
to equalize the benefits that they think
the Muslims are gaining but all this is
working within a political system the
démocratique political system because
the government sees is as an opportunity
to cut their leaders votes of both
Christians and Muslims and now the
political parties even make sure that
those contesting for political office
have our people of a certain religious
orientation the governing party for
example the New Patriotic Party has a
Christian president and then a Muslim
vice president and that kind of those
kinds of negotiation are going on all
the time and both Christian and Muslim
leaders are consulted in these
appointments supporting Muslim hajj or
pilgrimage is a major means by which
various governments have so - supported
islamic course to hide villages have
been set up by the government in tamale
and Accra with the one in the capital
located near the airport it is for the
fear of incurring the displeasure of the
government and presumably that of the
Muslim community that Christians may
have kept silent over government support
for the Muslim Hajj indeed when in the
midst of the media exchanges the
moderator of the Presbyterian Church of
the right reverend professor emanuel
marty fu Jian publicly called on the
government to stop sponsoring Hajj
there was a swift response from a Muslim
group through the internet giving him 24
hours to draw the statement that did not
happen but it raised a broader issue on
the disquiet
that is that a suspected sponsorship and
facilitation of the hide by government
raises within sections of the Christian
community there were even read as
letters in a couple of newspapers from
some members of the public presumably
Muslims who pointed to several areas of
Christian work in Ghana that receives
government sponsorship and so the system
of religious equalization goes on
between Christians and Muslims as we
have noted historically Jerusalem has
had more significance for Christianity
than any other city in the Middle East
Jerusalem is the first city in which
Jesus went through the major events
culminating in his crucifixion Jerusalem
is the city where the disciples were
expected to wait for the outpouring of
the Holy Spirit and it's also the city
that hosts some of the major landmarks
of the Christian faith as reported in
the Gospels the book of Revelation also
talks about a new heaven and a new earth
and of the holy city the New Jerusalem
coming down from heaven the reference in
the scriptures Jerusalem as a heavily
city has given its earthly version added
significance within the political
developments of Ghana and other
countries theologically Jerusalem has
remained in a Christian imagination as a
replica of the place where Christians
would spend eternity and this biblical
image of the descent of Jerusalem as a
high velocity inspired been out of
Clooney in his 12th century him
Jerusalem the golden
one of the stanzas of that hymn reads oh
sweet and blessed country the home of
God's elect all sweet and blessed
country that eager heart expect Jesus in
messy bring us to that dear land of rest
who art with God the Father and spirit
ever blessed does him together with the
him Jerusalem my happy home is commonly
Sun sank at Christian funerals to
indicate a destination of those who
serve God faithfully when the departs
life Jerusalem in keeping with
revelation has survived in the Christian
imagination us an eschatological City
that would ascend from God and I believe
Jerusalem my happy home is a very very
calm on him Jerusalem my happy home name
ever dear to me when shall my Labor's
have an end in joy and peace envy when
all these eyes die heavily built walls
and pearly gates behold thy boo walks
with salvation strong and streets of
shining gold
it says Jerusalem a happy home my soul
pants for thee then shall my Labor's
have an end then when I die joy shall
see
so traditionally Jerusalem exists in the
Christian imagination as a place
representing where Christians will be
for eternity but in the present context
of pilgrimages it has been reinvented as
a mecca the equivalent of Mecca in Islam
where Christians go on pilgrimage and my
point is that multiparty democracy is
fueling these sort of developments in
which Christians are a question for
funds to go on pilgrimage to Mecca let
me try and conclude
such hymns as I have narrated Jerusalem
the Goulding and Jerusalem my happy home
can help believers think about
themselves by providing a framework for
reflecting upon contemporary experiences
and given life a sense of direction for
those who have had the opportunity to
visit Jerusalem and it's related cities
for the just reasons it has served the
purpose of bringing the Bible alive in
terms of some of the descriptions of the
Ministry of Jesus Christ in the course
of the public discussion on the
appropriateness or otherwise of the
proposed Christian pilgrimage to Israel
it's emerged that some Pentecostal
charismatic Christians in Ghana who have
been there in the past have even sought
rebaptised 'm in the Jordan scene that
are small authentic than the irelia
baptism in Ghanaian waters the visit to
Jerusalem which is undertaken by
Christians all over the world has for
many years generated into a major
tourist endeavor given the level of
interest many tour companies have
established regular trips for Christians
and non-christians alike who are
interested in visiting Jerusalem in the
minds of those inclined towards a
theological import however it is
considered important to institutionalize
pilgrimages to Israel in order to put it
on the same pedestal as the Islamic Hajj
so what we have in this presentation is
a situation in which Christians have
tried to establish their own pilgrimage
site although legisla and theologically
speaking this does not exist in the
scriptures or if you like in
conventional Christian theology theology
an important part of these developments
that most of the arguments miss though
is that there is a whole
ten Zionist movement that has emerged
within Pentecostalism in particular
indeed in conversation with the leading
Ghanaian Pentecostal pastor who favored
the Jerusalem pilgrimage he was keen to
point to the historical importance of
the nation of Israel in the Christian
faith citing that as an important reason
for every Christian to try and visit the
place an important international voice
in this movement is the Catholic
Charismatic theologian Peter Hawking who
writes that Israel is the soil of the
Incarnation God's dealings with the
chosen people always reflect a
relationship between the particular and
the in vessel between the chosen people
and all the nations of the earth for
whose sake they elect are chosen and a
good the attempt to create a Christian
equivalent of mecca by seeking to hold
Jerusalem has been as important to the
Christian faith as Mecca is to Islam
raises critical issues that affect both
political developments and theological
matters in the political arena the
sponsorship of religious pilgrimage
seems to serve the interest of the
various governments in terms of
Allegiance support and booths in the
theological realm Christian pilgrimages
may be undertaking as important part of
personal and communal renewal however
the submissions of Jesus Christ and the
subsequent post resurrection history of
the faith indicate that there's really
no jus graphical Center meant to be the
focus of Christian encounter with God in
the words of Paul to the Athenians who
sought to domesticate God in the
eruption of a physical abode dedicated
to an unknown God
Paul says from one man he made every
nation of men
that they should inhabit the whole F and
he determined the time set for them and
the exact places where they should lay
God did this so that men would seek Him
and perhaps find him though he is not
far from each one of us and of course in
other words Paul seems to be suggesting
God is spirit and those who seek to
worship Him must do so in spirit and in
truth Jerusalem I conclude may be
significant for some reason but God
where Christianity has no black stone to
which we are required to repair for
religious credits so my point is that if
Christian some Christians have money and
they want to visit Jerusalem there is
nothing wrong with that but they attempt
to institutionalize the place equivalent
the Christian equivalent of Mecca does
not fit the theological importance of
Jerusalem within Christianity thank you
very much
so I recently learned about a case study
in Canada about a Jewish school in
Ontario that was seeking funding for the
school from the government and it was a
case that went up to the Supreme Court I
believe in Canada because in their
constitution is some reference to their
being funding available for private
Protestant schools and it went all the
way up to the Supreme Court and sort of
more recent amendments to the
Constitution that talk about sort of
having more equity between religious
communities they thought that those
newer amendments would sort of outweigh
the older constitutional guidelines but
it went up to the Supreme Court and they
upheld the original Constitution and
said that still you know we will only
find Protestant schools with the idea
that if we start funding more than
products in schools we're funding all
schools at this point so I wonder if
there's in sort of akin and context a
similar so I understand that it's like
the government that's controlling a lot
of kids but whether there's sort of
constitutional limitations to it and if
there haven't been sort of it if it is
something that has been you know you can
take into a corner yeah thank you now
officially Ghana is described as a
secular state in the Constitution and
even what we are calling Mission schools
and now virtually sponsored by the
government so the actually mission
schools in name
so you find sue sue Catholic Primary
School or Catholic High School or
Methodist High School or vegetarian high
school primary school they were started
by the missionaries but they are now all
government-owned government pays the
teachers
and so whether you attend a Catholic
school you attended a Methodist school
it's so paid for by the government the
churches have some limited room and
their support is so welcome
but in practice most of the schools are
sponsored by the government now what the
churches or religious institutions
particularly preset Christianity and
Islam what they have started to do now
is to set up private schools over which
they would have complete control in fact
a number of these schools even take for
an exam like Cambridge exams and a lot
of the children who attend these schools
are for middle-class homes so they can
afford to attend Ian versus abroad and
so on and so forth so we have ha we have
not had that sort of situation in which
somebody has to go to court to contest
these things but everybody understands
that is a political game because until
the Christian started asking for
sponsorship to go to Jerusalem it was
public knowledge that the Muslims was
receiving some support but the point is
that multiple multiparty democracy has
brought that development a sharper focus
you know and people feel that if the
government is going to continue to
sponsor Islamic events then we may as
well as for a share of the of the cake
because after we had the majority that's
that seems to be the argument that
Christians are making I don't know what
is going to happen in future and whether
the sicilian sustainable at all but i
can say to you that in the past two or
three decades the Muslim presence in
Ghana has become a bit more pronounced
and the Christians feel that part of
that visibility comes from political
patronage for example
and as I said the political parties
there to men for car parties in Ghana
and go out of their way to make sure
that Muslims are represented at the
highest level and I think mainly for for
votes and so on so we're not sure how
that is Goodwin but we don't we don't
have that kind of legal case yet there's
a hand also increasing disability
I hope you aware of some documents and
their meetings by Muslim countries we
give you to get in control you know
there are suffocating countries having
Sharia laws and so on and so forth so I
don't think it's entirely and you know
due to internal dynamics of the Canadian
nation I think there's an element of
influence well in terms of the public
discourse on this people refer to the
external influences to in fact the
Ghanaian public the Christian public in
particular was very concerned that our
last president John Mahama Aldo was a
Christian am i think visited Dubai many
many many many times including spending
most of his holidays there and as it
turned out there was sponsorship from
that part of the world for various
projects in in Ghana in fact the Islamic
investor which I I refer to it's
entirely sponsored from one one Islamic
country and so on so generally people
are aware but unfortunately we usually
don't come across the empirical evidence
supporting generally people know that
that is happening and suddenly when you
drive around the various capital cities
cities is a striking how prayer please
Islamic prayer please are springing up
being squeezed into even residential
areas and people are selling their
property for Muslim causes and so you
find most everywhere people yes pecked
that there is some extent of funding him
poor involved in orders
sorry we might say that they are Nick
toto but the fact that you said the
university was sponsored that you had
this you know foreign funds coming in
he's never enough evidence to support
the fact that there are so as denied
influences if the funding is coming from
I want to dispute that but that's just
one example that one can cite the point
I'm trying to make is that there is a
suspicion and there are many more
projects around I refer to the Islamic
that the Hajj village for example this
is a huge facility near the airport
where Muslims converge proud to
embarking on the Hajj and people suspect
that the funding for burden of the place
come from external sources we have a new
airport in tamale which is the main city
of the north and we know that has been
built into that Airport mosque and
people so that the airport is itself is
being built by by Brazilians a Brazilian
contractor but people believe that there
is some sponsorship for that project
from the Arab world and so the
government was left with no option we
hear that the building of the mosque as
part of the airport was one of the
conditions of providing the resources
what I'm saying is that I haven't cited
them here because I don't have the the
evidence the hard evidence to support it
but generally as their guy in public
talks about these things they know what
is going on
where you end it was the pilgrimage is
enshrined in Islam it's part of the code
as you know the established code doesn't
matter where Muslims lived that
obligation is part of the faith and
there is no such uniform established
institutional obligation for Christians
even for Catholics really that's really
where you end up and then the paradox
that hits me that strikes me in all of
this internally there seems to be you
talk about religious equalization but in
fact the process of getting there is
really just competition going on and
what strikes me here is the sort of lack
of balance really between the fact that
Muslims are fairly well organized around
the pilgrimage across a fairly well
organized they don't have to debate
about it they don't have to discuss a
clean or not agreeing when to go where
to go it's all set for them well the
Christians don't have that advantage
yeah
in order for Christians to really
compete it seems to me the Democratic
Party pluralism of Ghana requires
Christians to play a political game
the people made yourself a maker there
are prayers for the pilgrimage well
there is no political reference
whatsoever and the press you know our
prayers to God and memory of the
prophet muhammad maker and Medina's holy
cities and doing rituals that are not
rationalized by any political criteria
which ones that in imitation of the
Prophet so even some of the Rabia does
not play a political role but Christians
that find themselves having to play a
political game in order to think that
they might gain equality with Muslims is
that strategy ultimately self-defeating
for Christians that strategy so
defeating for Christians hmm I have a
thought about it
I have a thought about it but I have
raised questions regarding whether the
approach is the best because not only
did the Christians have to deal with the
Muslim community they also have to do
with themselves because publicly the
Catholics and the mainline Protestants
would come out and say this is not a way
to go and then you have independent
church pastors and leaders say no we
should go with it you know so the
Christians themselves are not speaking
with one voice you know so it's almost
like so that that's why I see I see it's
been self-defeating because one would
would have thought that if we're going
to deal with it then you just tell the
government get out of Legos business but
they're not doing that you know so
that's
mohamad autobiography that he wrote I
remember him saying that he had a strong
feeling that the north in terms of
education was neglected by the
government - and I I wondered if the
support for Muslims to go on hard to
them began on his presidency and also
whether this might explain his embrace
of help from the Middle East since he
dad did have this strong feeling that
the South had all good stuff and all the
support was someone even though he was a
Christian so I wondered whether you know
he's being a northerner had something to
do with the beginning of support
hmm I said if you called one because
although he said nothing I think Mihama
has spent a lot of time in the South and
interestingly he is not just he's not a
mainline Church Christian he's an
Assemblies of God
it's a Pentecostal denomination you know
and I think it's somebody who also goes
to church regularly of course in recent
during his tenure people questioning his
Christian commitment because of certain
things that happened and the leanings
towards the Arab countries and so on
requesting that but I would think that
the support comes more out of political
considerations than than anything else
because although in terms of
infrastructure the north has suffered a
lot that is not the only place in fact
the Far West of Ghana is one of the most
undeveloped places across the country
although most of our resources come from
there
most of our natural resources in terms
of gold and timber bauxite so on cuckoo
come from the West but everybody talks
about enough I think
the under development in the North
occurred because right from the start it
was determined that since that place was
predominantly Muslim Christian
evangelization there should be measured
a new crease evangelization took place
more through education and so at a time
everybody realized there were a lot of
educated people in the south and not
nests were not as as educated and they
have also been being discussion the
country garden why educated North nests
don't want to serve in that part of the
country you know you have a lot of
medical doctors and lawyers and so on
who will prefer to serve in the South
than to go up north and that's that's an
issue so so been being debated so my
point is that I think it's more out of
political than considerations than
anything else yes not because he comes
from in the second and third century for
Isis
so is this does it make sense to African
religious sensibilities this idea of
because you know in Egypt and Ethiopia
has always been part of we know Nubians
did quite a few pilgrimage and there's
actually Ethiopians in Jerusalem in the
fourth century shortly after they became
kind of a Christian country says it does
seem like footage makes sense
maybe not to the modern religious mind
[Music]
well it's always been there has always
been there people like to connect with
the sacred spaces that have meaning for
their faith one of the most popular
pilgrimage sites in Ghana today is a
mountain mountain called the abyssea
mountain so people call that we are
mounting and I've been there twice
myself and you know people are now
spending weeks on that mountain and they
travel from all over the country
converging the place to pray because
number of years ago maybe 50 years ago a
Methodist minister was driving around
the place
said to have had a voice saying that
that was a sacred mounting and now you
know everything institutionalize people
go to our mountains to pray and if you
go there and look at the very difficult
conditions under which people stay up
there you wonder you know for some of
these places the testimonies that go
with it that encourage patronage so
they're more people come with stories of
healing the more you find people go in
there so that there is something in the
human psyche that drives us to go on
pilgrimage to two places just look at
the average Catholic who steps in room
for the first time you know of Europe II
through relics then these large
Cathedral churches would have famous
like the relic of st. markers as well
except saying you would go to this so
cities became part of the Christian
story in some ways in ways that heard
that but you don't find him in the Bible
but now there cancer he wishes in cities
because of these relevance all kinds of
things have developed I mean for a very
long time those of us who have shown
interest in contemporary expressions of
Christianity like Pentecostalism thought
that Pentecostalism is a movement
without much ritual but we can say that
anymore because sacred places sacred
personalities even things that have
touched their body you know have become
very very important I refer to these
days as the use of sacramentals that is
visible substances that convey invisible
power I'm sure you you you know I've
heard about the Nigerian pasta Enoch
attaboy you know kadoya is the leader of
the regime Christian Church of God and
you know kinda boy visited Ghana for
religious revival and after the meeting
young ghanian pastas went to the seats
on which he sat robbed their hands on
the seat and you know themselves so that
it can receive the same power on this
Nigerian faster faster you know and I'm
surprised that this is are happening
within contemporary Pentecostalism and
so I think the whole desire to connect
with something more powerful something
secret for whatever purposes benefits
that inner to people is what translates
into this idea of pure Magnussen in a
place that has I don't know whether the
the tomb that we have in Israel the Holy
Land as we call it now where the tomb of
Jesus at the actual tomb because I
debate this with the students the
support that I mean we can't locate
grapes that a hundred years old so we
keep debatable at the cephalic is
actually the original one and if there
was any sense that this was really the
original one I had don't think it to be
there today because there was a Marian
apparition in a part of Ghana and little
boy whose claims ups and counted this
operation went to tell his mother and
they had to go and call the Catholic
priests to come and verify that it was a
real apparition by the time the Catholic
authorities got there there was no son
left in the place people have collected
all the Sun decide to their homes the
father they found a creature you know a
whole day so if that's of work I was
Cove is confirmed with area where I have
people collect the stones to break it
take them away you know so
[Applause]
[Music]